christian dürr fdp fraktionschef jahr
2022 also der staat diese
regierungskoalition steht unter
vorzeichen wie wir uns vor fast genau
einem halben jahr während der
koalitionsverhandlung nicht hätten
vorstellen können nicht nur spüren wir
die wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
nachwirkungen des höhepunktes der korona
pandemie das alles rückt ja in den
hintergrund angesichts des
angriffskrieges russlands in der ukraine
und die schrecklichen bilder die wir von
dort täglich sehen die zerstörung und
das leid das wir dort sehen sind
schrecklich und jegliche unterstützung
die wir leisten ist richtig und
notwendig ich möchte daher an dieser
stelle noch einmal deutlich sagen egal
was wir tun wir dürfen uns an die bilder
aus der ukraine nicht gewöhnen meine
damen und herren wir dürfen uns diese
bilder nicht
und wir reagieren indem wir eng an der
seite der ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
stehen die auch für die europäische
freiheit kämpfen wir unterstützen
finanziell ganz konkret den ukrainischen
staat damit erweitern von funktioniert
ganz konkret in diesem bundeshaushalt
abgestimmt mit den g 7 stellen wir eine
milliarde zusätzlich deutsche steuergeld
zur verfügung um die funktionsfähigkeit
des ukrainischen staates aufrecht zu
halten auch das ist ein wichtiges signal
dieser haushaltsberatungen über kollegen
und
wir schaffen etwas weiteres mit diesem
bundeshaushalt es ja schon viele war
stellen auch gesprochen worden beim
generalbundesanwalt der
bundesjustizminister beim
generalbundesanwalt schaffen wir stellen
für die verfolgung von kriegsverbrechen
meinen damen und herren diese
kriegsverbrechen in der ukraine dürfen
nicht ungesühnt bleiben hier um die
täter verfolgen meine damen und herren
auch von deutschen strafrechts gehoben
wenn wir also über diesen bundeshaushalt
sprechen in diesem jahr sprechen will
über veränderte gegen gegebenheiten über
eine geopolitisch andere welt als noch
vor zwei monaten
sie steht ja insbesondere das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr im
fokus der bundeskanzler hat das hier
vorgeschlagen am 27 februar ich bin dem
bundesfinanzminister ausdrücklich
dankbar für seine verhandlungsführung
ich bin ihm dankbar dass er die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion davon
abgehalten hat die einen absurden
abzählreim am freitag durchzuführen
meine damen und herren wir schaffen es
mit diesem sondervermögen die bundeswehr
endlich so auszustatten wie sie
ausgestattet werden muss wie eine
moderne armee ausgestattet werden muss
das wurde in den vergangenen zwei
jahrzehnten sträflich vernachlässigt und
es dient nicht nur unserer eigenen
sicherheit
sondern das sind wir endlich auch den
soldatinnen und soldaten der bundeswehr
schuldig meine damen und herren ihm das
auch klar zu sagen
ein zweiter punkt der mir in dem
zusammenhang mit dem sondervermögen
wichtig ist wir weichen nicht von der
schuldenbremse ab wir schleifen nicht
die schuldenbremse im grundgesetz
sondern wir werden am freitag mit zwei
drittel mehrheit dieses sondervermögen
beschließen was speziell der bundeswehr
zur verfügung steht und vor allen dingen
herr kollege merz wer erhöhen nicht die
steuern ich war heute morgen sicher dass
der oppositionsführer viele fragen
erneut stellen wird oder eigene konzepte
vorzulegen aber an einer stelle haben
sie mich belangt überrascht damit war
nicht zu rechnen
der spd vorzuwerfen
sie hätte den soli abschaffen müssen
damit sie jetzt als cdu/csu
den vorschlag machen können den soli
fahren menschen wieder ernsthaft rhein
zu führt wie absurd ist das denn meine
damen und herren das ist die neue
finanzpolitische kompetenz der cdu csu
und deutschland liebe kollegen polit
absurd was beinahe vorab russland ich
hätte es mir nicht träumen lassen ich
hätte es mir nicht träumen lassen
diese
bundesregierung herr merz diese
koalition ist mit einer doppelten
hypothek der 16-jährigen und jüngst
geführten bundesregierung gestartet
erstens eine vernachlässigte bundeswehr
ich sprach gerade darüber und
andererseits eine sehr gefährliche
abhängigkeit
von russland bei der energie deshalb ist
das im koalitionsvertrag verankerte
thema planungs beschleunigung der wollen
planungs beschleunigung in deutschland
so voran bringen dass wir die planungs
und genehmigungszeiten halbiert
dringlicher denn je hier sind wir in der
letzten sitzungswoche einen ersten
schritt gegangen mit dem ausbau von lng
terminals einen ersten wichtigen schritt
und ich schlage vor dass wir genau daran
anknüpfen sollten wenn wir darüber reden
dass die wirtschaft in den nächsten
jahren massive investitionen tätigen
muss dann darf das ja nicht jahrzehnte
dauern dann brauchen wir schnelle
verfahren in allen bereichen der
wirtschaft der industrie in deutschland
und auch bei die infrastrukturvorhaben
des staates meine da muten das was wir
hier vorgeschlagen haben das was wir
durch den deutschen bundestag gebracht
haben bei den lng terminals mit der mit
dem ziel der energieunabhängigkeit ist
ja geradezu eine blaupause für weitere
projekte meine damen und herren um die
transformation der wirtschaft nach vorne
zu bringen kaum ein land der welt ich
will dass zum thema klimaschutz an der
stelle sagen kaum ein land der welt hat
in den letzten jahrzehnten so viel geld
für klimaschutz ausgegeben aber so wenig
für klimaschutz erreicht meine damen und
herren das müssen wir umdrehen wir
brauchen auch planungs beschleunigung
damit wir energie unabhängig werden und
endlich den klimaschutz entsprechenden
deutschland voranbringen und die
transformation unserer volkswirtschaft
liebe politik
und
diese
diese ampel koalition ist angetreten um
das leben der menschen in deutschland zu
verbessern das mag erst pathetisch
klingen aber das ist jetzt sehr konkret
herz denn das was wir jetzt sehen dass
die letzten wochen und monate für viele
menschen sehr sehr hart gewesen sind und
leider wahrscheinlich nicht einfacher
werden ich denke an die millionen
familien mit kleinen ankommen die die
gestiegenen preise jetzt sehr deutlich
spüren und dennoch alles dafür tun damit
ihre kinder alles bekommen was sie
brauchen ich denke an die gastronomen in
unserem land die erst unter der pandemie
und jetzt unter einem enormen personal
mal gelesen ich denke an die vielen
handwerksbetriebe die weiteren junge
menschen ausbilden und die jeden tag auf
die lieferwagen und auf ihre transporter
angewiesen ich finde es daher richtig
dass wir es geschafft haben in den
letzten wochen so viele entlastung auf
den weg zu bringen um all diese menschen
zu erreichen wir haben den kinderbonus
erhöht die heizkostenpauschale wird die
einmalzahlung in höhe von 100 euro für
transferempfänger die energie pauschale
in höhe von 300 euro für alle
erwerbstätigen die einführung des 99
euro tickets wurde gesagt und die
senkung der steuern auf benzin und
diesel die höhen in der einkommensteuer
dauerhaft und rückwirkend zum ersten
januar den grundfreibetrag der
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag und die
pendlerpauschale
meine damen und herren wir werden für
die unternehmen in deutschland das was
ich als damals nach haushalts und
finanzpolitiker in der opposition immer
gefordert habe nämlich den steuerlichen
verlustvortrag dauerhaft auszuweiten wer
in der vergangenheit als unternehmer in
deutschland
solidarisch mit dem steuer start war
weil er oder sie gewinne gezeigt hat mit
dem muss jetzt auch der steuerstaat in
schwierigen zeiten solidarisch sein das
macht diese regierungskoalition
liebe kolleginnen kollegen
und mehr entlasten gezielt und reagieren
angemessen auf die aktuelle
wirtschaftliche lage und die hohe
belastung der menschen in diesem land
heute tritt die senkung der
energiesteuern kraft um die pendlerinnen
und pendler zu entlasten und ich habe ja
die ersten meldungen dazu gesehen im
ersten schritt obgleich natürlich noch
alter alter benziner bis diese sozusagen
in den tank ist aufgrund der damals
höheren steuersätze trotzdem sinken
glücklicherweise heute morgen die preise
an den tankstellen wir müssen die
menschen im ländlichen raum weiter im
blick behalten 60 prozent der menschen
in deutschland wurden nicht in urbanen
zentren sondern sie wohnen im ländlichen
raum das sind viele pendlerinnen und
pendler das sind viele familien und
diese regierungskoalition erhält genau
diese menschen im blick auf das will ich
an der stelle deutlich werden und
wir schaffen mit diesem bundeshaushalt
etwas weiteres über bildung ist für
meine begriffe noch zu wenig gesprochen
worden heute morgen diese
bundesregierung bringt eine große bafög
reform auf den weg und sie finanziert
sie auch und nicht mit eines in aller
klarheit sagen weil das in den letzten
jahren ja ich muss das sagen herr merz
und die letzte
bundesbildungsministerin die über nicht
kann philosophiert hat kam ja von der
cdu ich will das in aller klarheit sagen
wir müssen an einer stelle in
deutschland eine gerechtigkeitsfrage den
hebel um leben die frage wie man im
leben voran kommt darf nicht vom
elternhaus abhängig sein sondern es muss
davon allerdings sein wie man sich
anstrengt in dem jeder muss die seiten
chance haben und das tun wir mit dieser
bafög bekommen
und ich will deshalb insgesamt diesen
haushalt in einem verhältnis setzen wir
erhöhen die investitionen um 50
milliarden euro das sind bis zum jahr
350 milliarden euro investitionen des
bundes mehr als jemals zuvor wir werden
die ausgaben für den bundeshaushalt
2022 um 77 milliarden aus euro
reduzieren und gleichzeitig machen wir
100 milliarden euro weniger schulden als
die große koalition
2021 wir setzen die richtigen
prioritäten und der bundeshaushalt
2022 ist der auftakt für den
bundeshaushalt des kommenden jahres
gehen wir hier in wenigen wochen bereits
diskutieren werden das ist der
unterschied zur unionsgeführten
vorgängerregierung und ich will das
sagen herr merz der immer mehr fordert
um gleichzeitig zu hoher ausgaben
kritisiert der passt nach meiner
rechnung an der stelle nicht zusammen
wenn es nach ihren vorschlägen jetzt
will ich auch ihre arbeit während der
letzten wochen als opposition zu
sprechen kommen wenn es nach ihren
vorschlägen geht würden wir in diesem
jahr als koalition 60 milliarden euro
mehr schulden machen das ist doch die
wahrheit der märz ich habe mir ihre
anträge im haushaltsausschuss sehr genau
angeschaut sie wollen 60 milliarden aus
dem energie und klimafonds einsätzen für
das was sie vorhaben also sie nutzen
eine rücklage von der sie selbst sagen
sie seien verfassungswidrig
das passt nicht ich frage sie welches
verfassungsorgan freuen sie hinter die
fichte geführt das
bundesverfassungsgericht oder den
deutschen bundestag herr kollege merz
das müssen sie beantworten
und trage ich sie wo ist ihr plan zur
rückkehr zur schuldenbremse wo ist
eigentlich der plan der union um zur
schuldenbremse im kommenden jahr
zurückzukehren ich habe es schon mal
gesagt und wiederhole es an dieser
stelle gerne die schuldenbremse ist bei
christian lindner und olaf scholz in
besseren händen als bei friedrich merz
und alexandra droben um das in aller
klarheit zu sagen
kollegen und
ich habe in der letzten bahn predige
öfter gesagt dass eine oppositionsarbeit
auch so verstehen muss dass man service
opposition ist in dem man intelligente
vorschläge macht und auch alternativen
zur regierungsarbeit vorschlägt gerade
weil die öffentlichkeit aus meiner sicht
ein anrecht darauf hat herr kollege merz
diese 60 milliarden die schlank weg in
ihren haushalts vorschlägen stehen
fehlen jetzt stehen zwar drin aber die
fehlen in der sache die fehlen in der
sache weil sie sehe ich sagen das sei ja
verfassungswidriges geld stichwort
service opposition das was wir in den
letzten wochen bei den
haushaltsberatungen der cdu/csu erlebt
haben das ist keine service opposition
das ist eine einzige servicewüste
gewesen meine damen und herren da ist
nichts bei rum gekommen
haushaltspolitisch gar nichts von dem
was sie da vorgelegt haben und deswegen
will ich zum schluss ein wichtiges thema
ansprechen was sie auch angedeutet haben
von ihrem idol ein kollege der cdu csu
fraktion auch gestern bei der debatte
zur finanzpolitik um den einzelplan des
bundesfinanzministers nämlich die frage
der altersversorgung in deutschland
diese bundesregierung wird den
nachholfaktor in der rente wieder
einführen wir priorisieren im haushalt
so dass wir entsprechend es auch
schaffen in zukunft in richtung
kapitaldeckung teil kapitaldeckung bei
der altersvorsorge zu gehen und ich will
ihnen das in aller klarheit sagen ich
bin da schon sehr sehr verwundert herr
merz sie sagen nach 16 jahren
verantwortung bei der rente sei es
irgendwie gescheitert sie haben die
bundeskanzlerin gestellt mit verlaub
nein das ist nicht ich habe hier
gesessen für ihre land nicht an der spd
alles gescheitert
dies vor allem die union gewesen die bis
heute keinen retten konzept vorlegen
kann bis heute haben die keinen
vorschlag zu machen wie es besser geht
und deswegen
will ich einen sehr konkreten
kürzungsvorschlag in sie vorgelegt haben
als fraktion aufgreifen sie kürzen bei
der beruflichen integration für
zuwanderer mag wie ein kleiner titel
erstmal klinge ich glaube das ist ein
verräterischer vorschlag weiter
innerhalb weit eine andere haltung stück
da steckt eine andere haltung dahinter
weil viel größeren thema ich will in
diese klare frage stellen herr merz
wollen sie mit dem historischen fehler
der eigenen partei aufräumen und
deutschland endlich zu einem modernen
ein wohnungsbrand achten oder neunten
dass sie in wirtschaftlichen interesse
unseres landes es ist im westen
nationalen interesse der bundesrepublik
deutschland dass wir endlich ein
modernes einwanderungsland werden denn
nur so werden die die fachkräfte
bekommen nur so werden wir die renten
der zukunft absichern auf diese zentrale
zukunftsfrage die diese
regierungsfraktion sich in die
koalitionsvertrag ist immer haben sie
nicht eine einzige antwort heute
geliefert nicht in der vergangenheit
hier handeln ich danke ihnen
[Applaus]